COLT MCANLIS: Hello, everybody.
Welcome to another episode
of "Google Developers Live."
My name is Colt McAnlis,
and today, we're
talking about a fantastic
technology inside of Chrome
known as the Native
Client project.
Now this technology
does something
that a lot of web developers
never thought possible.
You see, it allows you
to develop, distribute,
and execute native code
right in your web browser.
But here's the catch.
It's just as secure
as JavaScript.
Now here to talk about this
fantastic technology today
are some of the
brains of the project.
I'd like to introduce
our panel for today.
Hello, everyone.
Sitting next to me,
we have Erik Kay,
who's an engineering
director for Chrome,
as well as Molly
Mackinlay, who's
a product manager
on Native Client.
And also at the end is David
Sehr, technical lead for NaCl
and also one of the
inventors of the project.
Hey, listen, thank
you guys for being
here today on "Google
Developers Live."
MOLLY MACKINLAY: Absolutely.
COLT MCANLIS: We have lights
and all sorts of microphones.
Hopefully, it's
not too big a deal.
Anyhow, so Erik, tell us about
the Native Client project.
What is it?
What's its goals?
ERIK KAY: Well,
as you said, it's
about bringing native
code to the web.
So the question is, why?
And why should you
care about that?
Well, it turns out that
there's a lot of native code
that's been written out
there, a lot of C, C++ code.
And there's a lot of
expertise, a lot of people
who that's their
bread and butter.
They are developers
in C and C++.
There's a lot of
developers, also,
who need to use those
technologies because they
target a variety of different
platforms, some that require
native code in order
to get on them.
If you're targeting for the
iPhone, maybe you have a C,
C++, Objective-C app.
If you want to get
that to the web,
you need technology like Native
Client to bring it there.
COLT MCANLIS: And
that's going to help
us sort of get performance.
It's going to help us with
security and everything else,
right?
ERIK KAY: Right.
Portability,
security, performance.
COLT MCANLIS: Interesting.
Now David, you're
one of the creators.
You were there
from the beginning.
So tell us a bit
about Native Client.
What is it doing
under the hood that
allows it to accomplish
all these things?
DAVID SEHR: Put
simply, Native Client
is about secure execution of
native code in the web browser.
So we do this by actually
changing the compiler
that you would use to produce
the native code in such a way
that it produces machine
code that can only
do things that are secure.
The code that it generates
actually sets up something
that we call a sandbox.
And inside the sandbox, the
application can run in a way
that it can't gain access to
execution outside the sandbox,
except through very
controlled APIs,
and it can't have access to
other parts of the browser that
might otherwise
compromise security.
COLT MCANLIS: So it's
sounds like there's
sort of a component
on the compiler
side of the technology, as well
as a lot of machinery running
inside of the browser, which
is kind of a complex pipeline.
How much of this is actually
visible to the user?
MOLLY MACKINLAY: So from
a user's perspective,
when they navigate to a
web application that's
using a Native
Client module, it's
really a transparent process.
They get all the benefit
of the performance
we get with a Native
Client application,
but they don't have to go
through the classic plug-in
install gesture that we've
come to know and maybe not love
quite as much about the web.
So it's really much more
of a transparent process.
They're not having to interact
directly with a module.
It just kind of
helps them be more
performant in the
application itself.
COLT MCANLIS: Now I think you
mentioned something interesting
there, the sort of
plug-in dialogue.
This has sort of been the uneasy
surface of the web community
for about the past 20 years now.
When you see that
"please install,"
you're never really
sure if you're
getting something awesome
or something malicious.
But NaCl attacks this, right?
So David, how is NaCl actually
ensuring this code is secure?
DAVID SEHR: So we knew
from the beginning
that we were going to be running
code that came from the web.
So this can be kind
of a scary place,
and the whole plug-in
experience sort of taught us
that relying on the user
to decide what was safe
or what was not safe might not
be the best approach to this.
So the approach that
we took was-- actually,
I talked a little bit
before about this--
was we modify the compiler to
produce these sequences that
are secure.
When the application and when
the page actually starts up,
we check, through something
we call the validator,
part of the Chrome browser,
that this set of safety rules
that the compiler produces
are actually followed.
If the application does not
follow those safety rules,
the browser simply refuses
to start the application.
If those safety
rules are started,
then while the
application is executing,
we're still
monitoring and making
sure that accesses to
the operating system
or to other browser
functionality
are carefully
monitored and secured.
Any time any of those, again,
are violated, any those rules
for access to operating system
or browser functionality,
we will, again, terminate
the application.
And all of this runs in addition
to the existing Chrome sandbox,
which is used to secure
JavaScript execution as well
as Native Client.
COLT MCANLIS: So it's like
there's sandboxes in sandboxes.
DAVID SEHR: That's right.
COLT MCANLIS: It's just
sandboxes all the way down
is kind of what I'm hearing.
DAVID SEHR: That's right.
Defense in depth.
COLT MCANLIS: So now
some of these rules,
most developers could hear
that and say, my program
has to adhere to rules.
That's super spooky.
What does that actually
mean for the developer?
What kind of
limitations do they have
in the development
of their application?
DAVID SEHR: So we looked at
Native Client in the beginning.
And as Erik talked
about, we really
wanted to bring native code,
in general, to the web.
We wanted to put as few
limitations as possible
on this system.
So because of some of the
rules that we require,
if your application actually
has inline assembly code,
or if you're using .s files,
you may have to modify those
to follow the safety rules
that the validator enforces.
If you're using a just
in time compiler as part
of your application,
you're probably
going to have to
modify that also
to properly execute
under the environment.
But otherwise, we've
tried very hard not
to put any additional
limitations
on what developers can do.
COLT MCANLIS: So when Chrome
gets this package of bytecode,
it has to kind of
check through it.
What's interesting about
that for me, though,
is that it sounds like maybe
you're not just limited to C++
to generate that code?
DAVID SEHR: So we here at Google
have built the initial tool
chains.
We've built a C/C++ tool
chain and have focused most
of our efforts on that.
But the intent is
that developers
can go broad and do other
platforms, other languages.
Some of our developer community
have already picked up on this.
And in fact, we've
already had ports
of Lua and Python and Ruby.
There are people
actively working
on Go and other languages out
in the developer community.
You can pick up some
of this on "naclports"
or follow on our
discussion list.
But C and C++, you have full
access to the Pepper APIs
today.
Some of these other
ones, we're working
on developing and adding access
to the other Pepper APIs.
But otherwise,
language independence
is a goal from the start, and
we're well along that path.
COLT MCANLIS: And
see, this is the thing
that I've loved about the Native
Client project from the start,
really.
So I'm a bad
JavaScript programmer.
I like having control
over my memory access
and understanding the
performance characteristics.
And so this is something
I like because I
can bring this code and
these other languages.
But to be honest, this is a bit
of bucking a trend for the web
development community.
I mean typically,
since its inception,
we've kind of been drilled
into this one mindset
of single language,
single setup.
But what this is
really proposing
is opening the doors
to just all sorts
of new experiences
and new technologies.
So Erik, obviously this is big.
What do you feel that
the impact of this
is going to be on the web over
the next five or so years?
ERIK KAY: Well, I think
your example highlighted
one of the main changes
that this is going to bring,
which is that there
are many developers who
aren't great JavaScript
web developers.
They're C/C++.
They use the language
of their choice.
And this suddenly
allows them to bring
their tools and their
technology and their knowledge
and expertise to the web.
So it's going to open up the
web to even more developers
with a lot of
existing software that
hasn't been brought to the web.
Think about this.
There's a ton of
native code that's
been out there being developed
over the last 40, 50 years.
The effort to port that to
JavaScript is not trivial.
These things have
been vetted over time.
So you think of crypto.
You think of image filters.
You think of whatever.
You don't want to go
have to reinvent that.
So another interesting bit is to
think about the opposite user,
the user who is a
web developer first
and knows nothing
about native code.
So how are they going to
go take that native code
and port it over to
JavaScript themselves?
One of the interesting
things about Native Client
is they might be able to just
take an existing built module
that somebody else
built, somebody that
had that expertise, and
integrate into their web.
You want to add a Gaussian
blur to your image editor?
Great, grab this NaCl module
that does that for you.
You don't necessarily have to
know anything about C and C++
to do that.
You just grab the NaCl module
and integrate it with your app.
COLT MCANLIS:
That's really cool.
I like the point you make
about the vetted code, too,
because that makes me
think that one day,
I'm going to be able to
just included the Mars Rover
navigation controller from
NASA right into my web page
and use it for some crazy thing.
Now again, this kind
of a big vision.
How have developers
been responding?
Is anyone really-- how has
the uptake been with this?
MOLLY MACKINLAY: We've actually
had a huge developer response.
We've had over 300 applications
in the Chrome Web Store.
These aren't just
your mom's web app.
These are applications
that are really
using the full processing
power of the computer,
coming from really
high powered platforms,
things like "Tomb Raider"
and "Tank Riders,"
coming from Xbox 360 and PS3.
We have "Bastion," which
comes from the Steam platform.
And not just games, though
game developers really
use the cutting edge of
what a platform can do.
We've also seen good
adoption for things
like CAD modeling and
surgical simulations,
where you're cutting
open cadavers
and teaching medical students
all the different entrails
that-- lots of crazy
stuff going on.
But these are high powered
applications that are really
pushing forward what we
can do, which is wonderful.
Things like image
and video editing
that really are taking advantage
of everything Native Client
can offer.
COLT MCANLIS: Now
a couple weeks ago,
I know that it was announced
on the Chromium blog post
sort of a new, I guess,
flavor, if that's
the right version of it,
called Portable Native Client
or PNACL.
MOLLY MACKINLAY: "Pinnacle."
COLT MCANLIS: "Pinnacle."
Tell me a little bit
more about PNaCl.
MOLLY MACKINLAY: So PNaCl is
another flavor, as you say,
of Native Client project.
And what this does is introduces
an intermediate representation
between the language, the C
and C++ the developer codes,
and how a user runs that
natively on their computer.
And through this
intermediate representation,
we can make sure
that in the future,
as new hardware is developed,
we can continue to target all
the different users' computers.
With the original
Native Client project,
you had to compile once for
every type of user computer
you wanted to support.
With Portable Native Client,
we don't have that problem.
We translate on the fly, given
the user's hardware type.
This means that we're portable,
as we say in the title.
We're portable across all of
these different architectures.
Previously, because
Native Client
was this architecture-specific
binary, we had to kind of gate
how we let that out.
We needed to make
sure that we were
future compatible in the web.
And so therefore, we put
Native Client modules
in the Chrome Web Store.
With Portable Native Client,
you don't have that problem,
you don't have that gate.
COLT MCANLIS: So I
like what you say there
about sort of future proofing.
I mean everyone--
let's be clear here.
The buzz in the tech world
right now is less on software
and more on hardware.
We've got new devices coming
out in much different areas--
I mean, Google Glass and tons
of different Android things.
I'm personally looking forward
to Google Shoe, which is nice
because that means
PNaCl will support
whatever silicone-based
pump ups.
I remember the Nike pump ups.
Those to me were the
pinnacle of shoe.
Like, when I can
control-- that was it.
Anyhow.
So it sounds like there's
kind of a big move
here, from the static,
architecture-specific
compilation to this sort of
translation that then gets
turned into whatever the
underlying architecture is.
So this sounds like a pretty
big shoveling of code.
David, how did that
go with the engineers?
Was this like a monumental
effort, or was it pretty easy?
DAVID SEHR: It's been
a pretty big effort.
So we started with
the GCC tool chain,
targeting, as Molly
said, basically one
executable platform at a
time, so x86, 32, or 64.
And with PNaCl, we
wanted that to be
one platform-independent binary,
what we're calling a pexe.
So we started with
a tool called Clang,
from the LLVM tool suite.
And it produces bitcode.
This bitcode, we made
some modifications to,
to make it more
suitable to the web,
to being hosted over
time in a website.
And then once we
had done that, we
had to look at
translators for all
these platforms in addition.
The translators themselves
to each one of the platforms
are based, again, on
the LLVM tool chain,
on the back end
compiler for that.
And so we had to
build one of those
for all the supported platforms.
And we've worked with
some people externally
to add some more supported
platforms over time as well.
So it's been a lot of
work in doing this.
And also, the security
standard that we set with NaCl
was an important part of this.
So securing both the translation
process and the executable code
is done through Native
Client as it was before.
So it's been a long
development effort,
and the engineers, I
think, are very relieved.
We're all really happy
to be at this point now,
and I think really cool
things are to come.
COLT MCANLIS: And see,
I remember actually
reading some of the
original publications
you guys did on this.
And even back then, it
was really weird to me.
Like, wait, this sounds
like a huge amount of work.
But it sounds like the
team has done fantastic.
But then with the uptake
that has already been there,
I mean, that's amazing.
So now that you're moved on
to PNaCl-- or not moved on to,
but now that this
thing has rolled out--
what's different for the user?
If someone's developing a
NaCl app versus a PNaCl app,
how does the user experience
the two differently?
MOLLY MACKINLAY:
So for the user,
when they're navigating to a
page that contains a PNaCl app,
they still have that same
transparent experience
using all of the feature
set, the performance
that we enable
through Native Client.
But now, PNaCl applications
can be embedded in a web page.
You navigate to a tab.
You use the benefits of PNaCl.
You get tired of it.
You're busy.
You want to go and edit your
video in a different tab.
You navigate away.
And so now you have this
kind of seamless interaction,
where you're getting pages that
are powered by Portable Native
Client, but they don't have to
go through the same Chrome Web
Store install
process that you had
with the Native
Client executables.
So it's similar, very much,
from the user perspective,
but just more free-flowing
in the web at large.
COLT MCANLIS:
That's interesting.
And so some of the
examples you gave,
though, they talk
about basically access
to native resources.
You've got high powered compute.
You've got access to TCP,
UDP, and stuff like that.
So I guess this is
kind of the question
that the community brings up
a lot is, so, if I can just
browse to a random web
page, and they have access
to some of these APIs,
Erik, is this something
I should be worried about?
Is someone going to turn on
my webcam when I don't know?
ERIK KAY: Absolutely not.
As David pointed out
before, the security model
for Native Client basically is
exactly the same as JavaScript.
So Native Client really
can't do any more
than what we allow normal
web pages to do before.
The main thing is just the
code that the developer
uses to write that
and the performance
that they're able to
get as a result of it.
Native Client is sandboxed
from the underlying operating
system.
It can't directly access things.
So it only accesses
these capabilities
through APIs like
Pepper that we've
developed, which
basically mirror
what's in the web platform.
In fact, because of that, we've
been able to take Pepper APIs
and create JavaScript wrappers
for them called pepper.js
and expose that
to and script it.
So people can even target Pepper
as a cross-browser solution
for their applications.
COLT MCANLIS: Now see,
that's really interesting.
So you're telling me
that-- because one
of the big vocal points about
the Native Client technology
is that, sort of,
it's Chrome only.
But you're telling me
that targeting the Pepper
APIs and then this
pepper.js project sort of
allows you to take your
application that you've
targeted for Native
Client and actually get it
into other browsers through
the JavaScript route.
ERIK KAY: That's right.
And it won't be
quite as performant
as if you targeted
Native Client.
You might not be able to
take advantage of things
like threading, things
that aren't in JavaScript.
But yes, you'll be able
to get the portability
of cross-browser.
COLT MCANLIS: And
that's really cool.
It's a complex web,
so I'm glad that this
is sort of added to the project.
So talk about this
a little bit more.
When we talk about
accessing native resources,
one of the big ways
that developers
have been approaching
this problem for a while
has been with
NPAPI-based plug-ins.
And recently, it was
announced that we're
going to depreciate those.
So can you talk a little
bit more about that decision
and whether-- is NaCl a viable
solution for these developers?
ERIK KAY: Absolutely.
So as I mentioned
before, NaCl is
sandboxed from the
underlying operating system.
NPAPI is sort of the opposite.
NPAPI was intentionally designed
to give web developers access
to the underlying
operating system.
Now what that means,
unfortunately,
is it means there's no
security guarantees of it.
And so that means that if
the plug-in has any security
vulnerabilities, any web page
can take advantage of those,
can exploit those.
And as a result, it turns out
that plug-ins have historically
been the number one source of
web browser vulnerabilities.
By closing up, by
deprecating NPAPI in Chrome,
we're getting rid of that
one last big security hole
that has been sitting there.
COLT MCANLIS: And so that was
always the scary part, right?
ERIK KAY: That was
always the goal.
And it's why we
developed Pepper.
It's why we have built-in Flash
using Pepper and a PDF Reader
using Pepper.
Those are built into Chrome so
that we sandboxed those first.
And now this is just
closing down the others.
And so if you're an
NPAPI developer today,
NaCl can be used
as a replacement,
as long as you're not trying to
access un-sandboxed resources
in the operating system.
So if what you're
doing is using this
as a way to bring
native code to the web,
then NaCl is what you want.
If what you wanted was
direct, un-sandboxed access
to the operating system,
unfortunately, we're
closing that up now.
COLT MCANLIS: I think
this is the right thing.
The web should be about
getting information and about
trading ideas and
finding what you need.
You shouldn't have to walk
into that area of being
afraid to click on a link.
That's not the web you want.
You want free
information exchange.
So listen, this is
fantastic stuff.
We're talking about
big vision stuff
here, changing security
models on the web and the way
languages and the way
developers look at things.
So Molly, give us the vision.
What's next for the
Native Client project?
What's the six month,
eight month ramp?
What can developers
be excited about?
MOLLY MACKINLAY:
Absolutely, Colt.
So we have some cool new
stuff right out the door.
We want to get things like C++
exception handling in there.
It's something that, talking
to our developer community,
was something that they loved
about the Native Client project
and they want in Portable
Native Client as well.
And so we're working on,
right out of the gate,
adding that as
quickly as we can.
A big thing that we're thinking
about as we move forward
is performance.
We want the load time, when
you load a Native Client
and Portable Native Client
application in a page,
that translation time to be
as small as we can get it.
And so we're working on
decreasing that as we speak.
Another thing is the size of a
Portable Native Client module.
We want to decrease
that, optimize
every little last
megabyte that we can
and make sure that that's
as small as we can get it.
And finally, moving forward,
one of the big things
we want to work on is the
debugging experience, making
sure that we're really
receptive to our developers,
hear their pain points,
and try and optimize
for their development
suite and how
they go about making a
Native Client application,
so that's as smooth and
hiccup-free as we can get.
COLT MCANLIS: That's
good, that's good.
So it sounds like lots of good
things have already been done.
Amazing technology,
really trying
to change the face of the web.
And so we've got
a couple questions
that I want to get
to here in a minute.
But before I give the masses
their shot at you guys,
I got a question,
because this is really
one of the things I want.
When is NaCl coming to mobile?
That seems like the perfect
melding of these two worlds.
Can you talk about
that, anybody?
ERIK KAY: So we've been
focused on desktop.
So it's a little early to
talk about anything there.
But stay tuned.
COLT MCANLIS: OK.
I like that.
I'll take that.
All right.
Now the masses can get
their shot at you guys.
So let's take a look
at our questions
that we opened up
earlier in the week.
So first one, are
there any plans
to have Portable Native
Client communicate
to the browser via JavaScript
APIs, like asm.js does,
as opposed to the
Pepper plug-in APIs?
MOLLY MACKINLAY: All right, so
I can jump on this at first,
and you guys can hop
in with your pieces.
We don't currently have any
plans to have a Native Client
application talk
directly to JavaScript.
I think Erik talked a little
bit about pepper.js earlier on
and how that ties up with
the JavaScript libraries.
But for a Native
Client application,
when you have native code
that wants to communicate,
we really do want to route
it through a secure API
that we can make sure it's not
going to do anything malicious,
and we can contain that access.
And so really, what
the Pepper APIs do
is connect up with the
same sort of back end
fundamentals of the
JavaScript APIs.
And so as we add functionality
to the Pepper APIs,
that sort of coverage
of the APIs available
is going to increase.
So we don't have
any plans of letting
JavaScript-- direct
JavaScript API access.
DAVID SEHR: To build on
that just a little bit, one
of the design goals
of the Pepper APIs
was actually to provide
a securable and smooth
interacting with the browser
experience for plug-ins.
Actually, one of the
things that plug-ins-- Erik
didn't talk about this
with NPAPI, et cetera.
One of the constant
complaints was,
gee, when the plug-in
does something
that ties up the
JavaScript and makes
for an awkward experience
in the browser.
In the foreground, the
JavaScript is not responding.
You get that nasty
little pop-up that
says JavaScript
unresponsive or whatever.
So PPAPI was designed
with that sort
of jank-free experience in mind.
And also, having a separate
process that actually you're
running the native
code in is yet
another layer of
securing the application.
We really like the fact
that it's a separate process
and that if that
process crashes,
it doesn't take
down the renderer.
It doesn't cause some of
the awkward experiences
that people have come
to see with plug-ins.
COLT MCANLIS: Now answer
this really quick as sort
of a follow-up to that.
So the question was like, asm.js
interacting with the browser.
That's standard
JavaScript, right?
It's not really
accessing anything
that JavaScript's not exposing.
It's not doing magic, right?
Or am I mis--
DAVID SEHR: No, that's right.
It's just a subset
of JavaScript.
COLT MCANLIS: OK.
And currently, NaCl actually
can communicate back
to JavaScript
through postMessage.
So there is some
communication there, right?
DAVID SEHR: That's right.
COLT MCANLIS: Interesting, OK.
Good.
So number two, are there any
performance considerations
that developers should
take into account when
using PNaCl versus the old,
static compiled tool chains?
DAVID SEHR: There are a couple
of performance considerations.
Some of them are longer
term, and a couple of them
we will be phasing
out as concerns
over the next few releases.
So first of all,
Portable Native Client
is intended to be portable.
So if you've used assembly
code, if you've got .s files
in your build, or you've
got inline assembly code,
these are things that are
inherently non-portable.
So if you hand-coded
assembly code,
you're going to need
to find ways to do that
otherwise or not pick Portal
Native Client as the approach.
A second and something we're
working to phase out is,
for instance, some of the things
people were doing with inline
assembly or with .s files was
access to SIMD instructions,
vector instructions to
do all kinds of things,
appear in every successive
generation of most hardware
vendors' products.
We're going to be adding
SIMD instruction support
to the existing
set of performance
features of Portable
Native Client over time.
But at this point,
if you're expecting
to be able to use
SIMD instructions,
you'll probably need to wait.
COLT MCANLIS: And so
I've got to tell you,
I'm glad that SIMD's coming,
because that's really
the thing that took my hair away
back in the games industry was
trying to optimize the
right SIMD instructions
for the architecture and get
the right thing like that.
So great.
It's good that my blood
pressure can go back up again.
My doctor's going to
really appreciate that.
Next question.
So how much effort
would take to port
an app built using Native Client
to Portable Native Client?
DAVID SEHR: I
think the good news
there is if you've already
done the work to port to PPAPI,
unless you're using just in time
compilation or inline assembly,
the port should be very
simple, should be almost as
simple as just
switching the compiler
flag for your
makefiles, or whatever
build environment you use.
If you're using some
of those features,
then you will have to do
some work to get around that.
COLT MCANLIS: And so most
of the NaCl tool chain,
does it insulate you from this?
Is it two separate
tool chains, or how
would a developer
go through that?
ERIK KAY: Well, in the
SDK-- we have the NaCl SDK
is the set of tools you
download to build Native Client
applications.
And the SDK does its best
to insulate you from this.
So it's just a
config file change
when you build to target
PNaCl versus to target NaCl.
COLT MCANLIS: Good.
So it's pretty seamless, right?
I mean, obviously, the
devil's in the details,
but that's for
programmers to deal with.
So is there a public
timeline for allowing
Native Client across
all web pages,
not just apps distributed
through the Chrome Web Store?
I think we've kind of tackled
this pretty well, right?
ERIK KAY: That is
Portable Native Client.
COLT MCANLIS:
That's shipping now.
Go play with it
immediately at this moment.
That's good.
I love seeing a question,
and it's like, no, yeah,
we're good there.
No curveballs there.
Here's another one.
When will vector data types
and SIMD be supported in PNaCl?
DAVID SEHR: We're actively
working on that at the moment.
In fact, we'll publish some
data here fairly shortly
of what we're proposing
as the first set of things
that will be supported.
We don't have the
dates exactly set yet,
but we're working
on it as we speak.
COLT MCANLIS: Add the
"lower Colt's blood
pressure intrinsic."
I'd appreciate that.
Final question that we're
going to have for today
because I think we're
running out of time.
Will the TCP socket API
be available to Portable
Native Client applications
being served via a website?
ERIK KAY: So no, and there's
a good reason for that.
As we mentioned before,
the whole point of this
is to have the same
capabilities as web pages.
So if we come up with a
security model for the web that
would allow us to have
TCP exposed to JavaScript,
then we would expose it
to Portable Native Client.
But since we don't, since
the security model of the web
doesn't allow that
today, we're not
exposing any additional features
like that to Portable Native
Client.
COLT MCANLIS: Now
do they have access
to some of these
features-- because I've
read the documentation--
in standard Native Client,
right, distributed through
the Chrome Web Store?
ERIK KAY: Well, if
you use packaged apps,
you can use Portable Native
Client or Native Client.
And then, yes, you
can use the packaged
apps APIs to do
networking there.
But since the questioner
asked about on a website,
as opposed to--
COLT MCANLIS: On
a website, yeah.
ERIK KAY: In a website, no.
In a packaged app, yes.
COLT MCANLIS: Awesome.
Well, hey, listen,
thank you guys
so much for taking the time
to talk about Portable Native
Client today.
It's an exciting product.
I'm really glad to have
been associated for so long.
So hey, if you're
watching the stream,
and you want to know more
about Portable Native Client,
make sure you visit GoNaCl.com.
That's going to
be the place where
you get all of your
information, stay up
to date with announcements,
news, demos, everything.
Hit that.
My name is Colt McAnlis.
Thank you for staying tuned
for another great episode
of "Google Developers Live."
Thanks.